hey Ron I'ma be sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen today I partner with ajinomoto
who spotted this video to debunk that
video that a lot of you have asked me to
comment on about MSG this is a 2008 a
viral video by dr. Vincent valency
titled the truth about msg so yes it's
an oldie but it's racked up a lot of
views so I feel it's worth discussing
so dr. blonde Z is a doctor of
chiropractic not medicine so just wanted
to clarify and he's also a clinical
nutritionist so today I'm gonna tackle
some of the biggest questions and
controversies about msg that dr. valancy
covers in the video ok so let's cover
some of the most popular claims that dr.
buonsi is making so first is simply that
luta made in large amounts like in food
is toxic and causes damage to neurons
let's take a look at what he has to say
naturally it's a good thing but in the
large amounts that you get it in your
foods and in all the different additives
or places where it's used as an ad of an
additive it's going to cause damage to
the neurons so this is one of the major
claims that people make in the war
against MSG but here's the bottom line
evidence is very clear that the MSG that
we consume does not impact the glutamate
in the brain because it doesn't even
cross the blood-brain barrier
in fact the MSG we consume doesn't even
make it into her bloodstream the
research that dr. bollen see is quoting
found neurotoxicity in mice non humans
and not in primates and they had to use
really high levels by injection and in
isolation in the real world MSG is
consumed through food so not by
injection and as a part of food so not
in isolation furthermore at the FAO and
who expert committee as well as the
Commission of European communities
committee both confirmed that in humans
up to 10 grams of MSG in a bolus of food
does not increase blood levels of
glutamate or impact the brain the way
that dr. bull Anzhi suggested it
impacted mice the daily intake of MSG is
point zero 5 of a gram and when used as
a seasoning is totally safe with no
daily limit specified so let's put that
one to bed ok so his next big claim
is that glutamate causes mental problems
in children with autism and impairs
concentration in adults
let's take a look is it can cause a lot
of mental problems especially with
autistic kids or people that are having
even as adults problems with control or
focus the glutamate or the s barkay
actually excite the brain and give you a
loss of control because it's over
exciting the nerve impulses and suddenly
you can't even control your emotions if
you're an autistic child it makes a bad
situation worse you can no longer
communicate so it's not a good thing and
a high concentration that it comes in
again we can shut this one down really
really super quick by just reminding
ourselves that MSG and food does not
increase glutamate levels in the brain
because it does not enter the
bloodstream and does not cross the
blood-brain barrier this is being
confirmed in two publications there's no
evidence that MSG causes autism or
causes mental problems in children with
autism
there's just no physiological reason for
this to be true okay so next I want to
tackle his claim that glutamate over
excites you and you can't control your
emotions the pathological process by
which neurons are damaged or killed by
the over excitation of receptors for the
excitatory neurotransmitter glutamate
cytotoxicity has been shown to occur
after brain injury or stroke however it
has not been shown to occur after the
dietary intake of any neurotransmitter
including glutamate or choline which
makes acetylcholine or tryptophan which
makes serotonin bottom-line excitotoxin
see is response to brain trauma not to
what we eat okay so let's take a look at
another one of belong Z's claims well
what gives you control are certain
substances in your diet there are three
what are called branched chain amino
acids so if you're not eating the
correct amounts of protein you're not
going to have anything else to compete
with the absorption of the glutamate and
it's gonna be stronger acting if you're
lacking things like magnesium or other
nutrients you're not going to have
control either because the glutamate is
gonna run while here's the cool deal on
absorption 95% of the glutamate we
consumed free or bound
actually is never absorbed into the
intestines actually utilized by the gut
where it gets converted by the cells in
our GI tract into energy or other amino
acids in other words the vast majority
of our dietary glutamate never crosses
any biological membranes so there's no
need to worry that will become deficient
in some other kind of amino acids
because glutamate is some kind of
bullies well calcium can actually
potentiate or make the glutamate work
even stronger
so if I'm already out of control and I
use glutamate things going to be even
more like control and I add calcium and
it comes down to changing the balance of
nutrients inside and outside the cell
but what it means for you is you can't
control your emotions sounds a little
bit like this guy got as facts mixed up
ok so here's how calcium plays a role
glutamate in a scenario where
excitotoxin occurs neurons are exposed
to the neurotransmitter glutamate for
extended periods of time
this can lead to an influx of large
amounts of calcium into the cell which
activates enzymes that destroy the cell
so it's actually that the
neurotransmitter glutamate can enable
calcium overload which in turn can lead
to cell death calcium does not make
glutamate stronger but again this
actually has nothing to do with the
consumption of glutamate or calcium
excitotoxin II is the result of a brain
injury stroke or neurodegenerative
diseases
okay let's tackle some more claims do
you think that if you just saw a Chicken
McNugget there and it didn't have MS
Unit you'd think there was much taste
probably not it's the MSG that causes
that McNugget to taste so good it's not
that it's such good food it's that the
excitatory neurotransmitter has hit your
brain and told you that that MUC no it
was good the food industry loves that
you'll eat more you'll buy more you'll
do whatever they tell you to do because
they've filled everything with MSG the
problem comes when the Emmis she starts
affecting you like I said it can cause
damage okay so here comes the big claims
that eating MSG makes you eat more and
gain weight and usually these claims are
bound up in these conspiracy theories
about how big food is trying to kill us
here is the big truth animal studies on
msg have found that in
ejected MSG into the brains of rats and
mice cause them to gain weight but we're
not mice and we also don't inject things
into our brain without medical
supervision so what does the research
say about us well one study in 2008 that
often gets quoted on healthy individuals
in South China found that there was an
association between those who consumed
msg and body weight however there was
several variables at play here and the
actual intake of MSG in the study it was
difficult to quantify
in contrast a 2013 study in Vietnam
found that there was no association
between body weight and msg consumption
in Vietnamese adults as for making food
too good to stop eating msg or more
specifically glutamate as the desirable
and unique savory mommy flavor it's the
same compound and taste sensation we'd
find in foods like seaweed aged parmesan
tomatoes and Chavez and miso its savory
its earthy and it's undoubtedly
delicious but if it's single handily
making food addictive and forcing you to
override your inherent eating intuition
of course not
in fact research suggests that msg may
actually enhance satiety one said he
found that participants who ate a carrot
soup with MSG rated their subjective
appetite as being lower than
participants who ate soup without msg
when you have a healthy relationship
with food food that tastes good feels
good and is inherently just more
satisfying the other potential benefit
is that most restaurant food and
processed food is very high in sodium
one gram of table salt has 390
milligrams of sodium compared to 1 gram
of MSG which has just 120 milligrams of
sodium so a lot of households find that
they can actually cut back on added salt
by just adding a little pinch of MSG
this also means that you could make
brussel sprouts and broccoli and tofu
and other nourishing foods more
appealing and more delicious so you just
inherently want to choose them more
often ok let's go back to the claims
here exciting your reward system you're
eating the junk that they can give you
for almost no money
it's depleting your nutrients
you're becoming more malnourished and it
just drives itself what the what
okay so first MSG is making you eat more
and now it's making you malnourished
truth is the research suggests that
glutamate may provide significant
nutritional benefits for certain
populations who are at risk of
malnutrition so think about like the
critically ill or the elderly one study
found that elderly who were struggling
to eat due to loss of taste or smell
improve their nutritional status when
MSG was added to the food simply because
it made the food more enjoyable and
flavorful what an amazing and important
tool for long-term care facilities and
hospitals to lean on for this population
all right so here comes some of Boleyn
C's anecdotes suffering from everything
from fibromyalgia to lupus a number of
problems the main concern was though she
had severe headaches and she had to take
pretty strong medication to control
those headaches her diet wasn't all that
good we started by cleaning up her diet
as soon as we got the MSG or the
glutamate out of her diet in that high
concentration her migraine headaches
disappeared so did her lupus reaction so
obviously those artificial chemicals
that they put in your food can be
reacted to in fact okay so while
anecdotal stories have been actually
shown to be more powerful at persuasion
than facts or data unfortunately they
don't tell the whole story having said
that it's often been cited that MSG
causes headaches often called the
Chinese restaurant syndrome which is a
super problematic term by the way but a
lot of people describe it feeling kind
of like you've had too much caffeine in
fact if Emma she triggered migraines
then the majority of people would be
suffering from them on a daily basis
just from eating things like tomatoes
mushrooms and cheese all of which are
high in glutamate actually breast milk
is really high in glutamate and babies
who are exclusively breastfed are not
struggling with migraines every single
day what we do know is that some people
experience mild transient symptoms and
that is with a dose of three grams at
once without food that's a mega dose put
into perspective in order to get that
amount of MSG from food you would have
to drink a whole cup of soy sauce or
consume nine ounces of Parmesan cheese I
love cheese
but that's a lot of cheese otherwise
evidence suggests that these symptoms
are not evident when people don't know
that they're eating msg as for this
woman's unique situation it's very
possible that just reducing a lot of the
ultra-processed foods that also
potentially contain MSG while increasing
fruits vegetables and fiber all of which
are recommendations for managing lupus
is responsible for her reduction in
symptoms not the MSG in isolation okay
so here's the deal the safety of
glutamate inherently found in food and
in seasonings like msg has been
thoroughly researched and the findings
are conclusive you're good MSG has been
used in households and home cooking in
many cultures since 1908 and the average
person is consuming about 20 to 40 times
more naturally-occurring glutamate than
we do added msg it's time we stopped
calling our food hangovers Chinese
restaurant syndrome it is a made-up
ailment with racist undertones and no
evidence to back it up if you don't feel
good after eating Chinese fried rice
then don't order it or make it at home
with less fat and salt but we are all
about facts not fear here at Abby's
kitchen so I hope this video gave you a
little bit more confidence in our food
system a big thank you again to
ajinomoto for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
any diet questions that you want cleared
up subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]